afg unter beobachtung der
verfassungsschutz stuft die gesamte
partei als rechtsextremistischen
verdachtsfall ein lockerungen in sicht
bund und länder beraten über einen
stufenweisen ausstieg aus dem shutdown
bruch mit der konservativen
parteienfamilie in der eu regierungschef
orban kündigt den austritt der
ungarischen svp mitglieder an
die nachrichten des tages heute mit
petra gerster guten abend willkommen
an diesem mittwoch einem hochspannenden
nachrichten tag der noch andauert und
spannenden ergebnissen auch vom sport
mit rudi cerne hallo guten abend heute
entscheidet sich also wie unser alltag
in den nächsten vier wochen aussieht
länder chefs und chefinnen beraten
derzeit noch mit der kanzlerin wie wir
wieder langsam aus dem schatten heraus
kommen ohne eine dritte corona welle zu
riskieren sollten die beteiligten gleich
vor die presse treten sind wir natürlich
sofort dabei jetzt aber erst mal zu
einer anderen brisanten entscheidungen
die heute bekannt wurde
der verfassungsschutz hat die gesamte
afd als rechtsextremistischen
verdachtsfall eingestuft seit zwei
jahren gilt sie schon als prüfer unter
anderem wegen umstrittener aussagen des
thüringer fdp landeschefs björn hertl
prüfer bedeutet nur das was die partei
öffentlich sagt und tut darf beobachtet
werden
jetzt aber als verdachtsfall kann der
verfassungsschutz sie mit all seinen
mitteln aus stehen also etwa v leute
rekrutieren e-mails mitlesen
telefongespräche abhören nur für
abgeordnete gilt das erst mal nicht
nicole diekmann
die größte oppositionspartei hochgestuft
zum verdachtsfall außerplanmäßige
pressekonferenz bei der afd
sie sehen sich als politisches opfer das
man hier die chancengleichheit der
parteien nicht gebaut hat und dass man
hier kurz vor landtagswahlen und in
einem bundestagswahlkampf diese
beobachtung diesen verdachtsfall
ausspricht dass es wirklich einmalig und
skandalös zwei jahre lang prüfte der
bundesverfassungsschutz reden interviews
oder auch beiträge in den sozialen
medien und kam zu dem schluss dass die
afg ausreichend belege für den verdacht
liefert gegen die freiheitlich
demokratische grundordnung zu verstoßen
so soll obwohl offiziell aufgelöst etwa
der rechtsextremistische flügel
weiterhin großen einfluss haben spät im
vergangenen november beim parteitag in
kalkar stellte sich afg chef meuten der
sich zu den sogenannten gemäßigt
zählt gegen die rechtsaußen und
versuchte so seine beobachtung noch zu
verhindern
vergeblich der machtkampf in seiner rede
weiter anheizte erreicht nun eine neue
eskalationsstufe die zustimmung die
vermuten ja noch beim parteitag als ihn
gewählt hatten den braunschweig hatte
die war ja groß auch gegen mitbewerber
wie bröckelt überall herrn brender ist
es völlig egal ob er vom
verfassungsschutz beobachtet werden oder
nicht
mir ist es das nicht herr brandner ist
ja nun auch für ziemlich krasse
äußerungen bekannt auch das sind eben
äußerungen - in schwierigkeiten gebracht
haben
nun also verdachtsfall für experten ein
logischer schritt
die partei hat sich immer weiter
radikalisiert sie hat bündnisse
geschlossen mit rechtsextremen akteuren
außerhalb der parlamente der sogenannten
neuen rechten aber auch mit akteuren
beispielsweise der pandemie kritikerin
bis hin zu neonazis das hat immer wieder
in den vergangenen jahren ja für
schlagzeilen gesorgt insofern ist diese
einstufung inhaltlich folgen richtig
die gesamte fdp steht nun unter
beobachtung ein einschneidender schritt
in einem superwahljahr für die
verschärfte beobachtung durch den
verfassungsschutz wollte parteichef
leuten ja unbedingt verhindern theo koll
ohne erfolg allerdings welche
konsequenzen wird das haben nun ist
dürfte zu einer deutlichen vertiefung
des parteiinternen grabens führen wenn
das überhaupt noch möglich ist denn die
radikalen teile der partei werden gegen
parteichef leuten ins feld führen dass
er mit seiner warnung vor den rechten in
den eigenen reihen und beispielsweise
mit dem ausschluss des flügeln eines
kalbes die radikalisierung zu stark
betont habe und leuten wiederum zeigt
auf die radikalen und sagt er habe ja
erfolglos vor der einstufung durch den
verfassungsschutz gewarnt also unter dem
deckmantel der gemeinsamen empörung über
den verfassungsschutz dürfte es jetzt
hauen und stechen über den künftigen
kurs der partei geben mitten im wahljahr
ist so eine entscheidung natürlich
gravierend was könnte das für die partei
bedeuten nun der ansehensverlust ist
natürlich enorm wenn der
verfassungsschutz nach zweijähriger
prüfung und in einem rund 1000 seitigen
gutachten zu der einschätzung kommt dass
es sich bei der afg um eine
extremistische bestrebungen haben
dann ist das ein makel der der partei
erheblich schaden kann
beamte beispielsweise wollen sicherlich
nicht ins visier des verfassungsschutzes
kommen und gemäßigtere wähler könnten
abgeschreckt werden aber das muss nicht
so kommen die afg steht jetzt nur noch
bei rund zehn prozent und die kern
anhängerschaft der partei hat sich ja
auch bisher von anderen auswüchsen wenig
bis nicht abschrecken lassen in jedem
fall dürften die anstehenden
landtagswahlen an die erste antwort
geben danke für ihre einschätzung zum
anderen thema des tages corona da steht
die bund länder runde gerade vor einem
dilemma einerseits verlieren die
menschen langsam die geduld sich weiter
an die strengen chor ohne
einschränkungen zu halten
andererseits droht möglicherweise eine
dritte ansteckungswelle nun soll ein
stufenplan helfen die balance zwischen
öffnungen und schutz vor dem virus zu
wahren wie der gedacht ist erklärt
thomas ganz privat mehr menschen treffen
ab montag wieder möglich so der entwurf
zwei haushalte dürfen zusammen kommen
insgesamt fünf personen plus kinder bis
öffnungen kommen demnach in fünf
schritten der erste ist schon gemacht
viele schulen und die friseurläden sind
auf wohl auch ab montag schritt 2 es
öffnen alle buchhandlungen blumen
beziehungsweise garten geschäfte und
fahrschulen
zugleich kann stufe 3 eintreten regional
schon da wo die inzidenz stabil unter
100 ist kunden dürfen dann wieder in
alle einzelhandelsgeschäfte in museen
und zoos aber mit termin buchung bei
einer inzidenz unter 35 ohne buchung
bleibt die incidents zwei wochen niedrig
könnte es ende märz heißen
außengastronomie wieder auf theater und
kinos auch je nach incidents mit buchung
nach noch mal zwei wochen mit guter
entwicklung sind draußen etwa
veranstaltungen mit 50 teilnehmern drin
aber steigt die incidents wieder über
100 sieht der entwurf eine notbremse vor
es gelten wieder die jetzt aktuellen
regeln
das hauptproblem 16 länder und den bund
in der korona politik unter einen hut zu
bringen mit all den unwägbarkeiten wie
sich das virus
weiter entwickelt vor allem auch
angesichts der neuen mutanten
dabei geht es auch um eine effektivere
impfstrategie und mehr schnelltests
andreas ruppert über die
unterschiedlichen stimmen die kanzlerin
merkel heute bündeln muss 14 uhr
kanzleramt corona gipfel wieder einmal
die immer gleichen bilder reingehen
stundenlange videokonferenz- dann das
große warten auf ergebnisse
klar ist schon im vorfeld es wird
gelockert schrittweise denn die menschen
im land sind corona müde sehnen sich
nach normalität die politik unter
zugzwang
das wird heute ein bedeutender schritt
sein weil wir nicht nur auf den totalen
lockdown setzen sondern weil wir neue
mittel hinzunehmen und das ist das
testen das impfen eine strategie raus
aus dem schatten sind also schnelltest
sie sollen allen bürgern mindestens ein
mal pro woche kostenlos zur verfügung
gestellt werden auch in schulen oder
kitas können sich personal und kinder
ebenfalls wöchentlich testen lassen
genau wie in unternehmen deren
mitarbeiter nicht im home office
arbeiten können längst überfällige
schritte so die fdp
wir bleiben weit hinter dem zurück was
jetzt möglich wäre
die grundrechtseingriffe die unseren
alltag heute noch bestimmen die sind für
den gesundheitsschutz nicht mehr
alternativlos dem impfen wird weiter
hohe priorität eingeräumt hier setzen
bund und länder auf mehr impfstoff mehr
tempo und künftig auch das mitwirken der
niedergelassenen ärzte wir brauchen die
arztpraxen die unseren in zukunft
unterstützen und ich kann es tatsächlich
nicht verstehen warum es nicht schon
diese verständigung mit den
niedergelassenen ärzten gibt wann und
wie sie starten können noch tag die bund
länder runde noch vielen die konkreten
beschlüsse nur eins steht schon fest
nächstes treffen ist am 22
märz in berlin beobachtet schack und
heller banerjee die runde schack und
allah ist dauert alles sehr lange was
ist ein diesmal der knackpunkt es geht
ja um einen grundsätzlichen
strategiewechsel in der korona
bekämpfung weg von der maximalen
eindämmung des virus hin zu einem
schrittweise wiederhochfahren des
öffentlichen lebens und da wollen
natürlich alle sicherstellen dass wenn
sie diesen schritt gehen die
infektionszahlen
direkt wieder durch die decke schießen
wir haben jetzt gehört das erst mal zwei
stunden lang über das impfen diskutiert
wurde dann zwei stunden lang über das
testen und dann ist man überhaupt erst
zu den details gekommen die man noch
besprechen muss und von denen es wohl
noch sehr viele gibt ein detail das wir
schon erfahren konnten ist dass der bund
ab dem 8 märz die kosten für kostenlose
schnelltests übernehmen soll
also das könnte jetzt relativ schnell
kommen unsere ein standbein sein also
der große knackpunkt ist sicher stellen
dass die strategie dann am ende auch
aufgeht
vielen dank unter der banerjee und jetzt
der blick auf die grundlage für das
alles die zahlen dieser virus krise in
fast der hälfte der positiven tests wird
mittlerweile die sogenannte britische
mutante nachgewiesen
das robert koch institut meldet außerdem
heute insgesamt 9000 19 neue infektionen
an einem tag das sind etwa 1000 mehr als
am vergangenen mittwoch 418 weitere
menschen sind an oder mit cupid 19
gestorben
die sieben tage incidents liegt
bundesweit bei 64 mehr zu den aktuellen
plänen von bund und ländern gibt es hier
direkt im anschluss in einem zdf spezial
und heute live überträgt die
pressekonferenz nach den beratungen mit
verfolgen können sie das in unserer app
seit jahren kommt die
bundeswehr-eliteeinheit ksk nicht aus
den schlagzeilen immer wieder gibt es
fälle von rechtsextremismus und immer
wieder verschwindet munition
jetzt ist ein kommandeur unter druck
geraten er hatte soldaten ermöglicht
patronen und sprengstoff anonym wieder
abzugeben ohne dass strafen drohen
der verteidigungsausschuss des
bundestages befragte dazu heute
verteidigungsministerin kramp
karrenbauer bernd benthin berichtet
tausende schuss gefechtsmunition und
zwei granaten so viel kam zusammen als
das ksk seinen soldaten erlaubte
gehortete munition straffrei wieder
abzugeben
dem verantwortlichen kommandeur
kreitmeier eigentlich angetreten um das
ksk zu reformieren droht jetzt ein
disziplinarverfahren
ich will dazu noch einmal sehr deutlich
sagen dass er die entscheidung zur
sammelaktion munition im ksk alleine
getroffen hat seit jahren sorgt das
kommando spezialkräfte für skandale
nachdem im garten eines ksk soldaten in
sachsen ein waffendepot und
rechtsextreme schriften gefunden wurden
ordnete das ministerium eine
untersuchung an
im bericht der dem zdf vorliegt heißt es
jetzt auf grundlage der bisher
gewonnenen erkenntnisse ist
festzustellen dass im ksk die
vorschriften für eine ordnungsgemäße
munitions bewegung und das meldewesen
zum beispiel im zusammenhang mit
festgestellten bestands differenzen in
den letzten jahren grundsätzlich nicht
eingehalten wurden wenn über jahre
hinweg im ksk mit munition fahrlässig
umgegangen worden ist
wenn bei so einer sammelaktion wie sie
beschönigen genannt wird 6000 schuss
gefechtsmunition zusammenkommen dann
sind das keine lappalien sie sind
einfach noch zu viele fragen offen die
geklärt werden müssen aber das problem
ksk ist viel tiefer
die herren generelle mit 234 stern auf
der schulter müssen sich fragen lassen
was sie die letzten jahre eigentlich
gemacht beziehungsweise nicht gemacht
haben dass kramp karrenbauer von den
vorgängen nichts wusste
daran hat die opposition starke zweifel
wie es mit dem ksk weitergeht will die
ministerin im sommer entscheiden
einen dauerstreit der großen koalition
ist beendet das lobby register soll
kommen
öffentlich einsehbar für alle das ziel
transparenz statt versteckter
einflussnahme professionelle
interessensvertreter müssen sich künftig
noch vor der kontaktaufnahme in ein
register eintragen
inklusive angaben zum auftraggeber und
zu finanziellen aufwendungen bei
verstößen droht ein bußgeld von bis zu
50.000 euro
vertreter der opposition
die pläne für unzureichend seit jahren
liegt ungarns ministerpräsident orban
mit seiner christdemokratischen parteien
familie in europa über kreuz jetzt der
offene bruch
orbans fidesz-partei verlässt die
fraktion im eu parlament kommt so eine
suspendierung zuvor
hintergrund ist die auseinandersetzung
über grundwerte und rechtsstaatlichkeit
konkret geht es um seine flüchtlings
medien und justizpolitik aus brüssel
anne gellinek das beziehungsdrama endet
mit einem knall viktor orban macht
schluss zieht seine zwölf fidesz
abgeordneten aus der europäischen
volkspartei ab der fraktion der
christdemokraten im europaparlament
der ungar kommt damit dem rauswurf zuvor
am vormittag hatte die svp fraktion mit
breiter mehrheit für eine
satzungsänderung bestimmt ab jetzt
können abgeordnete einer ganzen gruppe
sowie fidesz suspendiert oder
ausgeschlossen werden klar war dass die
fidesz partei unter führung von viktor
orban in den letzten jahren sich von den
werten von kohl von adenauer
verabschiedet hat und deswegen ist der
heutige schritt
schade ich will dass europa zusammen
bleibt aber er war leider gottes nicht
zu vermeiden
lange hatte vor allem die deutsche
cdu/csu gezögert sich von orbáns partei
zu trennen
der ungarische premier dagegen wurde
immer angriffslustiger ellis anti
brüssel plakate in ungarn kleben hüllt
presse und asylrecht aus und wehrt sich
gegen strafen für die veruntreuung von
eu-geldern jetzt also zieht orban die
konsequenz per brief die
satzungsänderung sei ein feindlicher akt
seiner abgeordneten in brüssel sehen das
genauso ich finde es unglaublich dass in
der mitte einer pandemie in der europa
gegen das virus kämpft die vp nichts
besseres zu tun hat als ich in einer
kleinkarierten debatte über ihre satzung
zu verstricken
die zwölf abgeordneten werden bereits
von der rechtsaußen fraktion im
europaparlament
mental umworben die entscheidung war
überfällig zu lange haben sich die
christdemokraten hat sich die gesamte eu
von viktor orban auf der nase
herumtanzen lassen
die späte erkenntnis das brückenbauen zu
autokraten schlecht am ende das eigene
fundament in myanmar geht die
militärführung immer brutaler gegen die
protestbewegung vor
die vereinten nationen gehen von 38
toten allein heute aus es sei der
blutigste tag seit dem militärputsch vor
einem monat gewesen
trotz der gefahr gehen die menschen
weiter in massen auf die straße noch
einmal zurück zu kroner da machen die
usa beim impfen rasante fortschritte
inzwischen hat fast jeder sechste
mindestens eine spritze bekommen zum
vergleich in deutschland erst jeder
zwanzigste und präsident joe biden
verspricht schon bis ende mai werde es
genügend impfstoff für alle erwachsenen
im land geben
das wären zwei monate früher als bislang
erhofft ermöglichen könnte das der
dritte jetzt in den usa zugelassenen
impfstoff auch weil er von mehreren
herstellern produziert werden darf
und gerade eben wird aus schweden
gemeldet bei einem mutmaßlichen
terroristischen stichwaffen angriff sind
sechs menschen verletzt worden so die
polizei
mehr wissen wir im moment noch nicht und
damit hat er bruch sind wir bei dir und
den sport rudi genau vor wenigen minuten
zu ende gegangen eine weltpremiere in
oberstdorf erstmals bei nordischen
ski-weltmeisterschaften sprangen die
frauen von der großschanze sind gold gab
es dabei für die norwegerinnen waren mit
bi die im finaldurchgang 130,5 meter
weit sprang
simon hat meter dahinter als beste
deutsche juliane seyfarth aus ruhla auf
rang zehn mixed weltmeisterin katharina
althaus erreichte am ende platz zwölf
so und sebastian vettel durfte heute
seinen neuen rennwagen enthüllen den
aston martin amr 21 in gaydon in england
wurde der bolide per internet
vollgestellt erster eindruck sehr grün
ein zufriedenes lächeln huscht über sein
gesicht sein neues arbeitsgerät sieht
zumindest schnell aus vorbei die
schwierige zeit und der ärger in roth
ferrari ist geschichte sein engagement
für erst martin soll eine erfolgreiche
formel 1 zeiten anknüpfen
persönlich bin ich natürlich am start um
zu gewinnen ich glaube dass das thema
viel potenzial hat zu zu glänzen und zu
überraschen und dass es unser ziel der
ersten martin r 21 ist grün wie die
hoffnung im dfb pokal viertelfinale
zwischen mönchengladbach und borussia
dortmund kassierten die gladbacher
gestern eine schmerzliche niederlage
die vierte nacheinander seit
bekanntwerden des abschieds von
cheftrainer marco rose und das
ausgerechnet gegen dessen künftigen
assistenten sind erst wirft seinen
künftigen chef den noch gladbacher marco
rose durch einen treffer des dortmunder
sancho aus dem pokal
dafür wird es von seinen spielern
gefeiert und da will es sich tatsächlich
noch zu große assistenten degradieren
lassen in dortmund es geht darum dass
ich in welcher rolle auch immer mein
bestmögliches geben werde um der
mannschaft zu helfen um den zehner team
zu helfen und welchen titel ich da habe
das ist mir voll kläger seine spieler
empfinden womöglich ganz anders
ja das was vom sport peter danke rudi
und wir haben jetzt noch die zahlen von
mittwochslotto sie lauten 1 19 23 24 27
und die superzahl 4 weitere gewinnzahlen
finden sie auf lotto punkt zdf.de und im
zdf text auf seite 55 7
morgen kommt bewegung ins wetter von
westen kommt regen von norden kälte und
selbst gewitter sind möglich mehr dazu
gleich von katja honnefer so viel von
uns danke für ihr interesse
natürlich bleiben wir am ball was die
krone runde betrifft im zdf spezial
gleich hier im anschluss und natürlich
informiert sie dann bettina
aus dem heute journal über alles
ausführlich einen interessanten abend
also bis morgen 19 uhr
[Musik]
genau meine damen und herren morgen
passiert gleich zweierlei zwischen dem
hoch bei island und dem tief bei
helsinki kommt kühle luft in richtung
mitteleuropa voran und ein kleines tief
zieht vom ärmelkanal weiter richtung
tschechien
das macht sie schon heute nacht mit
regen hier zwischen dem sauerland und
dem niederrhein bemerkbar
da liegen die tiefsttemperaturen bei
sechs grad deutlich kälter wird die
nacht in bayern mit minus 1 bis minus
zwei grad und morgen liegen die
temperaturen zwischen nur noch vier grad
an der ostseeküste und maximal 15 grad
am oberrhein und die regenwolken ziehen
weiter nach osten und besonders am
nachmittag kann es in den mittelgebirgen
dann auch mal gewitter geben am längsten
freundlich bleibt es noch am alpenrand
am freitag sinkt die schneefallgrenze in
den mittelgebirgen bis auf 400 meter und
das bei temperaturen von null bis sieben
grad das wochenende wird dann schon
wieder deutlich sonniger aber wenig
milder schön aber noch